Education is in and of itself a personal
benefit,
personal,
right,
actually,
that people have in a democratic
society.
Uh,
so before we get to a discussion of
benefits,
let's talk about education as a right.
Each person in a democratic society
as a right from the earliest age,
let's say age three all the way through
and including
couch
to have a fully funded paid education.
This should be one of the foundational
purposes of government.
Now,
when a child has the chance from the
earliest age age to learn languages
to learn English communication skills,
they then become able to participate in
a community.
And as young people grow,
that community keeps expanding from
this,
from the village to the city,
to the world.
We need to have our young people the
best educated in science and language
and the arts and music and literature.
Um,
technology.
I mean there's so many different areas
of human endeavor that our children
should have the chance to excel it.
But you know what?
Check out the cost of tuition and Iowa.
My friends ask yourself how many
families are being excluded from having
their young people be able to go to
school because they just can't afford
it,
and then let's talk about the world.